la droite républicaine a toujours été
engagée pour protéger les femmes et les
enfants c'est un combat de longue date
ce combat il commence avec simone veil
la loi pour l'accès à l'île et j'ai
était une des premières lois de
protection des femmes et de protection
de leur liberté et puis nous avons porté
nombreuses loi sur l'établissement de l'
ordonnance de protection c'était sous
nicolas sarkozy de mesures de protection
d'urgence des femmes et la dernière loi
c'est celle que j'ai eu l'honneur au nom
de mon groupe politique de notre groupe
de porter à l'assemblée nationale votée
à l'unanimité de l'assemblée nationale
et du sénat qui a permis d'accélérer les
procédures d ordonnance de protection
ainsi jour en six jours désormais on
sait protéger une femme est de
généraliser notamment le bracelet anti
rapprochement
[Musique]
depuis que nous sommes dans l'opposition
nous n'avons pas baisser la garde sur ce
sujet et là où gouvernement a beaucoup
parlé là où madame schiappa beaucoup
baratiner nous nous avons cherché à agir
nous avons porté une loi votée à
l'unanimité tous les bancs de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat ont
voté la loi que nous avons porté ce qui
veut dire que autour de nos valeurs nous
sommes capables de rassembler parfois
même au delà de nos convictions
politiques cette loi est une avancée
majeure elles généralisent le bracelet
anti rapprochement c'est ce bracelet qui
permet de protéger les femmes en grand
danger elle permet d'avoir un meilleur
accès au logement pour les femmes
victimes de violence de faire en sorte
que la règle désormais ce soit
l'éviction du compagnon violent et le
fait que les femmes victimes puissent
rester dans leur logement nous avons
aussi travaillé sur la suspension de
l'autorité parentale pour les hommes
violents parce que d'un mauvais mari un
mari violent ne peut pas être un bon
père
avec valérie pécresse nous avons voulu
faire de ce combat pour la protection
des femmes et des enfants des familles
dans lesquelles la violence déchire une
priorité nationale parce qu'on ne peut
pas être la france parce qu'on ne peut
pas avoir les valeurs qui sont les
valeurs de notre pays s'en protéger
toutes les femmes et aussi longtemps
qu'il restera une femme victime de
violence dans notre pays nous nous
engageons nous engageons à faire en
sorte que les procédures en justice
soient accélérées il faut qu'en quelques
jours nous soyons capables de juger un
homme violent il ne faut pas que tout
cela traîne comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui et puis nous avons une
proposition forte celle de créer demain
des juridictions spécialisées c'est ce
qui s'est fait ailleurs en europe
notamment en espagne des magistrats
spécialisés qui associeront la
compétence civile et la compétence
pénale et qui permettront rapidement
efficacement puissamment de protéger
toutes les femmes tous les enfants qui
ont besoin de l'être dans notre pays
[Musique]